foreign
[Music]
Ty production
starring Joe bartnick
[Music]
foreign
also starring Bill Burr
and club soda Kennedy
[Music]
tonight's episode a killing in Chicago
ladies and gentlemen Joe bartnick
foreign
[Applause]
oh I love Chicago
's a drink in town
and I'm a drinker
now I live in L.A
it's more of a rehab town
people in La go to rehab for wine
like I drink a bottle of wine a day
I'm like yeah so does my mom
like yeah but I take pills I'm like yeah
so does my mom
drink up cowgirl
and I was talking to a dude
nothing sadder than a grown man drinking
a glass of white wine
like how about some soy milk in a sippy
cup
be more masculine
I drink a lot
I drink so much I got the gout
if you don't know what the gout is it's
basically a medieval drinking disease
it means you're drinking such your foot
hurts
there's no happy fun commercials for the
gout either it's not like HPV or herpes
there's nobody snowboarding or skydiving
with the gout
they're all dragging their dead legs
through a casino
where's the 5
doll Shack
[Applause]
glad the bars are open again
that was a terrible year and a half
for us alcoholics
remember Zoom happy hour
that [__]
open your bear look at your buddy in the
computer
I like an old dirty bar with a good
jukebox and Miller High Life
yeah
champagne
I like a bar before John Taffer rescues
it
[Applause]
[__] it up
hey John I didn't come to Sal's Saloon
for a perfectly made mint julep
I came for the buy one get three free
special
it always always opens up the kitchen
door like look how nasty that Grill is
hey John I didn't come to Sal's for the
cuisine
I can't because Wendy behind the bars
probably gonna show us her tits
you guys have a good pandemic foreign
people
smokers
the elderly
side chicks
not a lot of gumas but inside the bubble
it's hard to pretend you're going to the
store at 2 A.M
why do you needed CVS a [__]
I had a fun pandemic yep I got a new dog
and a mustache and a heart attack
yeah Don't Clap I lived
there's that pain to get in the back of
your leg in the middle of the night and
you wake up you're like [__]
I basically got that in my chest
but it was right in the beginning of the
pandemic so I couldn't go to the
hospital so I basically just walked it
off
I treated a heart attack like an ice
cream headache
a week after my heart attack I had to
have a procedure done to save my life
and during that procedure they had to
shave my balls
they asked for volunteers flaming gay
guy goes me
I'm like yes that guy loves balls he'll
take care of mine
but then raise her in hand he looked me
right in the hand he goes you remind me
of my ex-boyfriend
then I got scared
I'm like this guy's gonna laugh off my
left nut because Bruce never took him to
see Hamilton
yeah and older my friends are getting
older that sucks that's my buddy the
other day and he goes I got my party
pills I'm like he got molly he's like no
Tums
I'm like cool he's had some green chili
some of that [__]
I actually like heartburn it makes me
feel alive
breathing fire like a dragon
I'm at the age now where I pee in the
middle of the night
thinking about wearing a diaper to bed
just so I can sleep in
but if I get used to it start wearing it
around town
I'm on the subway people think I'm just
chilling I'm like
do the shake at the end
he's taking a piss
losing my memory a little bit so I
changed up my lifestyle
like now I wash my hair as soon as I get
in the shower
[Music]
so I don't start jerking off and forget
the worst you got you're like [__] I
forgot to wash my hair
gotta get back in turn the water on the
whole family knows he just jerked off
no when you get out of the shark and
still have shampoo in your hair you were
in the zone
Jordan in the garden
um I try I'm a little I'm trying to act
young though like I use emojis
I used to think emojis for like kids you
know I used to think texting was for
kids then I'm like wait I don't have to
call somebody
and it's like oh emojis you don't have
to text somebody
you know my favorite emoji is
thumbs up
yeah
yeah it's like [__] you we're done
no more bubbles [__]
I see bubbles I'll call your ass
the Emoji they need is the old man
Italian wave
yeah they get the [__] out of here
my wife hates that
[Music]
my grandfather had the best he did the
reverse
old man Italian wave
[__] yeah
I recently lost 70 pounds
[Applause]
fall back
I know what you're thinking he still
kind of looks like [__]
that's what I'm wearing a collared shirt
you got man titties you got to wear a
collar
yeah foreign
[Applause]
right off the top
that's why golfers wear it makes them
almost look athletic
like I can't wear a wife beater
you can't wear a wife beater if you look
like a wife beater
you have a six-pack where a wife beater
if you just drank a six-pack keep your
sleeves on
I know young girl like yourself you want
abs I get it
but the older ladies who've lost all
their hopes and dreams
he dig the dad the dad bod
[Applause]
Now ladies this body says fun
this body says everybody's getting
appetizers
nobody has to split dessert with his
body
is built for comfort
his body sleeps in on Saturdays
nobody has to get up and ride a bike
with his body
I hate people that ride bikes
not the guys that deliver food those
guys Benedict
but the guys that dress up like
Spider-Man
take up half the road
think you're not gonna hit him
those guys [__] you
uh most ran over one of those guys last
week anybody likes flashing their back
of his helmet
how am I supposed to see that I'm
looking at my phone
my wife wants me to keep the weight off
[__] [__]
[Applause]
she thinks I should go to bed hungry
[Music]
I'm like I'm I'm American
my grandfather did not go to war for me
to go to bed hungry
doesn't keep anything to eat in the
house she keeps almonds she's like you
must not be hungry if you're hungry and
eat the almonds almonds are delicious I
don't know
like oh
almonds aren't even food
you know how I know they're not food
because my dog doesn't give a [__] if I
mean
Ruby's like eating almonds going to bed
plus
I love the excitement dogs have and they
think you have food they want
they come running you like
and they find out it's like fruit or
nuts they're so disappointed like Ugh
yeah
it's like when you turn on Goodfellas
but it's on the Mexican Channel you're
like
[Applause]
when you have what they want they zero
in on you like they're so concentrating
like they don't break concentration
they're like
like the degenerate gamblers at the
table like
I always have to do the dealer hand
wiping
what are your Corners ladies
my wife doesn't I think I've heard of
it's called portion control
it's worse than communism
it's got these little portions of food I
think that's the portion you would get
in a restaurant
unlike not the restaurant where I know
the owner and I'm [__] the chef
because that's the restaurant I'm in
right now
[Applause]
so how about some more lasagna
first time my wife made me design you
had orange chunks in it
I know I'm like this [__] broad
put American cheese in my lasagna
[Music]
I gotta call my known again alone
she goes no you [__] that squash
I'm like gay racquetball
my wife uses Chopsticks at home
who are you impressing
taxes with an abacus
so I got a daughter she's really good at
basketball
she's so good the black kids pass with
the ball
I mean she's not ready for it but at
least we're thinking of her
like she can beat me sometimes when I
want she's like Daddy I know your
weaknesses on but you know about rye
whiskey and Ty hookers
her last year of organized balls she won
the championship and I got a big trophy
like this big I'm like [__] yeah you got
a trophy it's like I got tons of
trophies I'm like yeah
but this time you'll want something
that one's for seventh place
we're not teaching our kids about the
real world if your resume is in seventh
place you're not getting the job
six people have to fail a drug test
before you get that job
my daughter's 17 when she was little she
was so cute everyone's like wait till
she becomes a teenager you're gonna hate
her
and now she's a big [__] and I kind of
do
her and my wife argue constantly I never
get involved
[Music]
but the other night they were screaming
each other and my daughter goes I'm just
gonna go upstairs and kill myself
I was like whoa whoa whoa whoa
we just paid for braces
you're into me for 11 Grand you're
sticking around a while
but it goes to art school she thinks
he's artsy
she's like Daddy I'm gonna make soap I'm
like you don't even do the dishes
if he does battle ballet it's [__]
awful
the music's terrible all the mothers
hate me because I call the borrow Pole
I'm like your dial looks great on the
pole
where I come from we call it a pull and
she's gonna make a lot of money in a
couple years
you should be happy forget about college
buy a pair of tits
feeling good so happy I lost the weight
yeah because now I can shop at Marshalls
again
yeah because I can fit in double X
clothing
there's nothing left that marshes a
triple X it's all green or purple or
fuchsia
I can't wear those colors I'm not black
[Music]
[Applause]
guys look good bald
magic me ball
black guys looking in dreadlocks
white guy has dreadlocks you're like
[__] [__]
black a has to be like that guy's cool
he's probably got weed
black guys looking at bow ties white guy
has both eyes like you're an accountant
and a pedophile
black guys even look good in glasses
and they're just wearing them for the
irony they're not going to read
take it easy
I can handle the racism I'm white
I'm not even really white I'm Italian
we want to wait until the 40s
oh Frank Sinatra and Joe DiMaggio
you have to be really good at something
then they'll let you be white
like Obama they let him be white
friends Prince was white
OJ was white for a while then he [__]
it up
[Applause]
Will Smith is the whitest man alive
he assaulted a black dude and they gave
him an award
Tiger Woods is white again
I love tiger man he's my favorite
drunken [__] Monger I [__] love that
guy
I love tiger so much I used to listen to
golf on the radio
people get so mad like how can you
even
that's exactly why you cheated on her
because she's beautiful and gorgeous you
know she just lays there in bed and
doesn't move
she doesn't have to
she's beautiful
but Tiger's got a billion dollars he
wants someone to lick his ass
like only someone who works in
Applebee's can
[Applause]
the gym was shut for a year that was
cool
hey I hate all the fake happy people at
the gym like still you're not gonna live
forever
chick at the front desk on way too many
red bulls what are your goals
I'm like the [__] you later
I think I'm here for my health
you're the treadmill for a half hour
because I'm an Ultra marathoner
I type in a half hour it doesn't
going
called the cool down
[Music]
total [__]
who has not more walking on the
treadmill it's the joint in the car on
the ride home
well I used to love weed
no now I can't handle it it's too good
yeah when I was a kid weed was brown it
had sticks and seeds in it
you're rolling a dragon hi you were
lucky you threw a frisbee
now it's purple it's called Luke
Skywalker's nuts
smoking Joy they got lay down for a week
I wake up I can't remember any of my
passwords
that's all I do all day is keep updating
has to be a number seven letters well it
has to be capitalized
I've been through the whole Penguins
roster four times
you have to prove you're not a computer
it's like I can't remember the name of
this tree to grow up on I'm pretty sure
I'm not a computer
they ask you an emotional question like
what was the name of your favorite pet
it's the love Ruby now I have Rosie I
don't know
or they put 10 photos which would then
have a stop sign
I'm blind I got to call my kid in to
help me
I'm blind I went to Lenscrafters he goes
you drove here
I actually failed the DMV eye exam
man lady goes you need enough right I go
what do you need to do she goes I don't
worry about it
we waited in line for three hours we'll
let you drive
my buddy came out from New York City and
he wanted to go in and out burger I'm
like I'll give you a ride
and we're driving down the street and I
go hey uh what's that sign saying he
goes you can't see that sign I'm like
dude if you knew what I couldn't see you
wouldn't be in this car
be taking an Uber you cheap [__]
I had an incident two Sundays ago
I drove through a street fair
I mean there was [__] going on but I
didn't think the street was closed
the cops were cool
The Real Housewives of Sierra Madre not
so much
it's like relax Donna I didn't knock
over your dream catcher stand
so uh I got I did get a new dog
during the pandemic now I have two dogs
I just I just love dogs I mean if I was
a billionaire I wouldn't shoot myself in
the space I'd buy every [__] pound
and it'd be all my dogs
yeah I love noise because I'm
narcissistic and I'm codependent
so it's all about me they just love me
I don't have to ask anybody else about
their day it's all about me
yeah we love you
love you people need pets everybody
needs pets everybody should have pets
but they should have dogs really like I
made the Asian hours some of my guy
friends have cats
I'm like I'm like is that your
girlfriends
then they're like no I'm like Ugh
you probably drink Pepsi
[Laughter]
yeah
have a Coke and get a dog [__]
[Applause]
Pepsi he would have tackled him
some people have Birds I don't know and
they teach them to talk I don't even
want my wife to talk
if I had a bird though I teach my bird
my Internet passwords
hey Toucan Sam what's Yahoo Malkin 71
exclamation point
[Applause]
some people have ferrets what's that
about
unless you're greased them up and
sticking them in your ass
why else
why else are rodents into your home
that people have guinea pigs hamsters
one thing you never see no one ever has
a raccoon
because those things will [__] you up
you ever look a raccoon in the eye you
get a chill down your spine
like I'm sorry I must be in the wrong
neighborhood
so I have Rosie the German shepherd He
also have my old dog Ruby the cutest
mutt in the world and she's like the
shot caller of the house
like Rosie's afraid of her
Rosie's 130 pounds Ruby's 30 pounds she
controls Rose it's hilarious she's the
best dog but she was paralyzed three
years ago
she's all better now but it cost me
seven thousand dollars to get her fixed
now she's the most expensive thing in my
house
and over the ground but there's a fire
where's the kid I don't know get the dog
[Applause]
the surgeon was nice but I think you
have to be when you're charging seven
thousand dollars to fix somebody's dog
25 donation in the dog's name
I would never put my dog I love that dog
my wife would never let me my wife would
put me down before the dog she'd have an
itchy trigger figure too
I better not even blink in a hospital
she's like he's gone pull the car
like we do 50k 50k for your kid what
would you do like if it was my kid I say
Tough Enough life isn't a favor get in a
wheelchair
you love Space Mountain right well now
you're first every time
[Applause]
you get the big bathroom now in the
parking space when you're older just
don't ever get on a bus because everyone
will hate you
the bus you're like [__] I was in a
hurry
even the driver's pissed you have to get
up and strap them in
what could go wrong he's already in a
wheelchair
I love drugs
yeah
[Applause]
found a new one this year Adderall
[__] awesome makes me wish I had a
stupid kid
I offered something to my wife she used
to cocaine like an adult
can't smoke anywhere but I love gummies
yeah
yeah one gummy drive my kid to school
talk to the teacher
four gummies hang out with my mom all
day long
incident free
who died again remind me oh yeah that's
right
some people think cbd's a drug I don't
know if you think cbd's a drug then you
think natural deodorant works
everybody has Facebook friends everybody
know who they are but they're your
Facebook friend right
someone was my Facebook friend they put
on my page if you love marijuana you
can't be my friend
I'm like who the [__] are you
she lived in Atlanta and she worked for
Taco Bell
you be against marijuana and work at
the whole reason you have a job is
because of marijuana
there's nobody so we're going I need a
chalupa
I I don't like Taco Bell I haven't eaten
one in 28 years
yeah I live in California we have real
Mexican food
I don't even like their commercials
their commercials offend me yeah the
newest one has is a beautiful there's a
beautiful home and like eight people
dressed nicely sitting in the living
room and you can Taco Bell on the couch
in the daylight
foreign
animals
they have access to a kitchen
you know you Taco Bell on the couch in
the daytime you talk about in the dark
in your car
I just don't I just don't like chain
restaurants how they even start like who
was at the first Chili's this food's
awful let's make a thousand of them
I'm sure Carl senior ran a great
hamburger stand
yeah
but then Junior had to go Nationwide
[__] it all up
there is one restaurant I do enjoy
that's Waffle House
yeah yeah
a bunch of animals in the crowd I love
it it was awesome listen to this though
I just saw an internet the other day
some guy ran naked through a waffle
house and shot a bunch of people
how [__] up do you have to be
to be barefoot in a Waffle House
[Applause]
[__] out
[__] out that person has no will to live
I love food food's the only drug I can't
handle
it's a drug it is you ever try to eat
one Dorito
you can't eat the whole bag and you're
licking orange dust off your fingers
like a [__] crackhead
there's a slice of pizza in my fridge I
can't sleep
oh
[Applause]
wake up at 5am like my kid's not getting
this [__] her
you ever eat pizza so hot or burns your
face but you keep eating it anyway like
[Music]
chicken parmesan That's My Heroine
I'll eat a whole tray until I nod off
that's my favorite type of day we need
so much you can do is take a nap and a
[__]
I have a word for that half English half
Spanish it's called a shiesta
would you say it took a siesta [__] yeah
man that's a good day
I love to eat but I don't like buffets
no I don't need a sneeze guard give me a
waitress
I was in Pennsylvania this guy goes the
buffet is amazing it's amazing
amazing it's amazing if you're a naked
afraid
it's like it's powdered eggs
the only time powdered eggs are amazing
if they're served by the Red Cross
I do like some buffets though the
expensive ones that have carving
stations and omelette bars you know
but I don't really like the chef the man
them though
Urban chefs used to be cool be fat guys
smoke cigarettes had checkered pants
like like just jolly old [__]
now they're all skinny they got arm
tattoos carry their knives around
do heroin they all think they're Anthony
Bourdain
it's like you're not writing the Great
American novel you're working at a
Marriott
they all make their own ketchups
plums in my ketchup
I want a bottle of Heinz
not hunts
hunts is the Pepsi of ketchups
yeah
I was uh I was dating my wife about two
months maybe maybe less than that and we
were to catch it we go go across the
street and get some ketchup and she came
back with hunts I'm like what the [__]
is this I go we're going back and we go
back to my corner store
in this corner store guy I mean he sells
porn to 12 year olds
in cigarettes to 10 year olds
and even he was like I'm sorry
[Music]
money back
let's talk some politics
[Applause]
I think I give a [__] about politics
my life was so much better when I didn't
know the name of any governor
including my own
yeah I mean I knew it wasn't
Schwarzenegger anymore
I voted for Terminator twice
[__] yeah you know when you're 15 who do
you want to be in charge Terminator
he was twice
I'm voting for The Rock for president
yeah he's like Obama on roids
put the people's elbow down on China
hey Putin you smell what The Rock is
cooking
the only political thing I am is I'm
pro-environment
yeah
no I mean I used to not be but then I
got a kid
yeah I mean they used to treat the Earth
like or rent a car
but now I'm like let's keep it around a
while
some people aren't though they're like
they're not they think we're gonna live
on Mars one day like when they live on
Mars I'm like what
maybe the Kennedys the Kardashians not
the 180 people in here on a Monday
[Music]
beer at flight to Mars
I love Spirit people don't like spirit I
love it yes tickets are cheaper than UFC
just as many fights
and they don't really have stewardesses
which is great
I don't know you like stewardesses they
just bother you they used to be cool
used to be air flirts like coffee tea or
me
not like Air Marshals like worrying
about your safety like just don't hit me
with the cart Bertha
all they do is give you garbage you have
to hand them back in five minutes
who needs this much ginger ale
facing they're basically just terrible
waitresses
can't get a job on land
well they have to fly to Cleveland three
times a week to pay their rent
laughs
they only do it with straws I don't care
I'm a man I haven't used a straw in 45
years unless I'm doing blow
but overall built from Mother Earth
but bring back paper towels [__] the
trees
it's like a washing my hands in the
men's room because I have to
because there's somebody else in there
my dad
the cleanest thing in the men's room
and you have to hit the syphilis machine
to dry them off
I mean any germs are in the men's room
let's blow them all around a while
bring back real paper towels too not
those one-third [__]
what's that for oh I knocked over my
Visine
I just don't like an environmentally
friendly bathrooms
yeah the sinks never work you're always
like
the lights are motion censored so if you
stop moving they go out
you're taking this [__] it turns into a
horror movie
[Music]
they want to do away with plastic bags
then where the home is going to use for
condoms
I'm sick of having to pretend to care
about homeless people
they're not cool
if they were cool they'd have a place to
stay
they're not homeless they're friendless
I'm glad you guys are in a good mood
yeah America is starting to get happy
again which is nice because before the
pandemic people were just sad for no
reason
like they were worrying about [__] that
had no effect on their life they
pretended to care
they didn't look at [__] they're
like oh I better put a sad emoji on
Facebook or gonna people think I'm an
[__]
so then like God was like oh you're I'll
give you something to [__] cry about
I'll shut the world down for two years
you want to cry about this [__]
remember pre-pandemic people like
Houston's underwater good
ever been to Houston
places are humid your ball is stick to
the side of your leg that place needs a
bidet
doesn't have any power
did they have power before the storm
so if they did that means they probably
had cable
that means they have the Weather Channel
because they have four days to see this
you see the storm coming
it's a hurricane it's not an earthquake
get a poncho Pedro
everyone used to be upset about school
shootings
that's one thing the pandemic did away
with school shootings
you can't shoot up a zoom School
as soon as one square goes out like lock
the door Johnny
foreign
I went to Catholic school when I was in
algebra class I wanted someone to come
in there shoot up that [__] school
and hit that penguin [__] first she got
a comment
I'm glad nuns are going extinct
jobs for angry lesbians to do
they can work at UPS they can drive a
tow truck
they can work at Arby's because they got
the meats
me and my wife are getting along better
sleep apathy
yeah it's where you snore but you're
asleep so you don't give a [__]
my problem
thank I mean I'm too broke to get
divorced
only rich people get divorced
yeah poor people just stay together and
hate each other
what's my wife going to do take half by
AC DC CDs
can't believe the judge gave her a
Highway to Hell
I'm too broke to kill my wife too
and get away with it
not like in an OJ where everybody knows
but in a way when only your
mother-in-law really kind of knows
yeah I used to be if you're rich you go
on a cruise you get international waters
you throw her overboard
but then some lady swam back and caught
the boat
imagine look on that guy's face
is it the buffet having some crab legs
she comes walking in soaking wet
he has to play it off
that's hilarious I knew you were coming
back oh
check oh I forgot to hit record
oh you're funny I'll buy a new one
no now if you're rich you go to a third
world country
you go hiking you find a high ledge and
you push her off
yeah there's no CSI Honduras
there's just one corrupt Detective
he's not looking for a killer he's
looking for an envelope
accident
see
[Applause]
a lot of nice couples in the crowd let
me tell you this if you're in a
relationship and you're arguing and you
don't have any kids
get the [__] out now
[Applause]
it is never getting any better
what are you talking about what's on TV
me and my wife were together for 10
years before we had a kid we only argued
five times
four of them are all in the same
canoeing trip
apparently I was too fat to sit in the
front
into lazy to sit in the bath
you're a nice couples if you don't have
any kids tonight here's my big tip for
the evening do not use the pull out
method
a birth control
apparently some sperm is more potent
than others
mine
crawled off her back
[Applause]
it's the truth
it's called The Love drop thank you for
the hot dog and then you squeeze the
mustard
and the first thing that comes out ain't
well now I call that Isabella
[Applause]
you guys are a great Sports Town
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah the Bears old school I'm a Steeler
fan yeah but I'm an old school student I
feel like I go back to Franco
in Lambert not there's all these
bandwagon fans
and they think they're big fans like I
met a guy in San Diego because I'm the
biggest Steeler fan in the world
it's like if you don't wipe ice off your
car you're not the biggest dealer fan in
the world
if your uncle hasn't been unemployed for
30 years
you're not the biggest dealer fan in the
world
I like old school NFL though nowadays
it's too much about player safety it's
like hey if you want to live till you're
70 drive a bus
that's why I love the NHL they don't
really care about player safety it's
like skate with your head up [__]
I love college basketball but in the
winter it gets very confusing ESPN is
supporting the women's scores on the
ticker in pink
so you could be in half asleep on the
couch I wake up Duke lost by 35.
oh that's women's basketball
I guess I need a bigger TV
so I can see the asterisk where it says
it doesn't [__] matter
[Applause]
they should put women's basketball on
Facebook
friends and family anyway
[Applause]
I do like some women's sports like
women's volleyball
take it to the beach ladies
who knew the Lithuanian volleyball team
was so hot
who knew there were beaches in Lithuania
those were Lithuania is
yeah those commie broads in their tight
panties
I love Serena Williams
yeah look at that ass all day long I'll
watch Serena hit balls off a wall all
day
I don't really like women's MMA though
I'd rather watch two sevens fight in the
parking lot
like what's your favorite move a hair
pool
[Music]
like you think Ronda Rousey is hot
yeah she's hot for a chick that can kick
my ass
she's not like stripper hot
like if she came up and asked you for a
lap day and she'd be like I'm not ready
yet
[Applause]
let's see who a champagne room Rhonda
I do karate
I do
in case I ever host an award show
[Applause]
I'll be like five swords [__]
I do karate because it's all young dudes
and they always like I'm the oldest dude
but like 20 years but it's fun to hang
out with younger people because all my
older friends just kind of suck
I don't do anything anymore and they
kind of get on me they're like What's
your retirement plan like my retirement
plan is to die
in a couple baseball cards
a couple mint Rod Carew is going to pay
the mortgage
like I'm old enough to be in the Viagra
commercial
but I've never used Viagra never had to
man look at the same steel I used to get
back in seventh grade
and I was breaking desks
feels like a rocket ship taking off in
your pants
you're the MTV Music
no now my erections are more like a
helicopter taking off
with the sad Mash music
grab a towel radar grab a towel
yeah I still do drugs though
that'd be smart though like now when you
do Coke you have to watch like nine
people do it
then wait like 15 minutes
okay it's cool
yeah it'd be smart doing drugs sometimes
you're not sometimes I'm not like right
before the pandemic I was doing cocaine
with my gym card
because I'm a baller
I went to the gym the next day and the
card still had cocaine on it
gave it to the chick at the front desk
she's like so I grabbed it back and I
licked it
and I went up on the treadmill and I was
Usain Bolt for about nine seconds
and I fell back and hit my head
and I woke up and there's like five
people standing around and the chick
from their front desk goes that's the
guy with the cocaine that wants to [__]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
I kid around about drinking and drugs
and Rehab
um you know but if you need to go Go I
mean I'll never go to rehab
because I have a swimming pool
if you need to go
please go I mean it because I've
personally put four different people in
rehab
I was the last person for different
women hung out with before they got
sober
it's rock bottoms
people say well what about your wife
okay I'm five chicks
you guys are cool
who's your favorite porn star
oh nice
you know who mine is Steve Jobs
he put porn on your phone
you know how important that is I travel
every weekend I can't be bringing DVDs
through TSA
try to download porn on your computer
gets computer AIDS and dies
you're in some small town you can't even
jerk off to the newscasters
the small Market it's that lazy eye
used to be there was one salvation
b-e-t uncut
[Music]
uncensored rap videos
Nelly Tip Drill was the best
I need a tip drill I used to have the
VHS when I came home
it was the best
it was from Midnight to three
but it ended exactly at three
no commercial break
yeah it went from twerking to the
Reverend
you don't know the spirit until you
played Beat the Clock while you beat
your [__] in calamazoo
foreign
lgbq XYZ it's like an eye chart I can't
read
they let fat people be gay now
before you had at least be in shape to
take a dick in the ass
[Music]
no everybody's under the rainbow
I'm ready to say it was binary I'm like
what's that mean because I mean they can
do dudes or chicks I mean you should
have just said you were cool
now you got to be pro-gay though
yeah if not you're just ignorant who
cares where somebody puts their dick or
their tongue or their dildo
unless it's in you and you don't want it
to be
I mean I could never be gay I have
hemorrhoids and sharp teeth
look at the way I address everybody
offer nothing to the gay community
the games on shop at Marshalls
well the lesbians do
can't beat two flannels for seven
dollars
gay race how about everybody though even
straight guys like me last week I was in
New York I do the bathroom really bad
and the men's room was packed
so I went in the ladies room
when they came out all these women were
pissed
I'm like hey I'm transitioning
from a guy that had to take a dump
to know a guy who doesn't have to take
enough
where's the parade
you guys are cool
some towns aren't there they get upset
they're like Bernard or gay I'm like
burnt under your puppets
like Tom Cruise is gay I'm like Tom
Cruise the Scientologist that is so much
worse
they got mad when they found out John
Travolta was gay
yeah his masseuse ratted him out his
masseuse wouldn't jerk him off so he got
fired
how stupid is that
he's rubbing him all over her anyway
what's the difference
let them lose your job over
I'd do it yeah that's Vinnie barbarino
has Vincent Vega
that's chili Paul Mary how bad could it
be
what's it like to work with Tarantino
hurry up okay go Grease Lightning
[Applause]
doesn't be great thanks for coming to
this comedy show if you've been to one
comedy show you've been to 100 right
here the same things right married guys
don't get enough [__]
the fact of the matter is married guys
don't get enough quality blow jobs
my wife sucks a dick like she's forced
to give a homeless man CPR
foreign
her sucking a dick like a mom trying to
save a melting ice cream cone
all right everybody I'm Joe bartnick
thank you so much Ricardo
[Applause]
next time on bartnick so
where are you from California where are
you really from Pittsburgh
was that so [__] hard
work neck this doesn't taste like
champagne
does to me
I don't do Happy Endings oh how about a
grand opening
[Music]
bam
oh
are you
oh that's varnick
yeah it is
[Music]